[Music]
okay what is up guys I'm Q PhD here and
I'm in Seattle right now for a
top-secret project that you guys will
see soon but over the past couple days
and for my trip to get here and so on
I've been testing a certain pair of new
headphones so you guys may have seen the
pictures you may have seen the tweets it
is already my new all-time favorite pair
of wireless noise cancelling cans this
is over the bose QC 35 2 s this is over
the Microsoft Surface headphones
it's the Sony WH 1000 X and threes
terrible name but these are the real
deal honestly there's really not all
that much you have to do to really nail
a pair of this category of over ear
noise cancelling headphones so you've
got to sound great you have to have good
noise cancellation and then you just
have to be somewhat comfortable and have
a fairly good feature set and as you
might imagine since I'm talking about
him like this these male all of those so
right off the bat with the sound these
sound excellent they're full rich and
clear with the sound they have more
range and more deep bass than the Bose
but without being overwhelming and short
of studio headphones this is a great
sounding crisp clean pair of drivers and
the noise cancellation is actually a bit
better than the Bose I was already
sacrificing a little bit when I switched
to surface headphones I think those
surface headphones had slightly worse
sound and slightly worse active noise
cancellation but I loved the design and
the comfort and USB type-c and the dials
and all of that so that put them over
the top for me these Sony's though sound
better than both are better at noise
cancellation than both and they have a
great design basically as soon as I
heard these I knew I liked them and
they've been sort of growing on me ever
since and also I wore these for five and
a half hours straight on the flight to
get here and they only really started to
get tight by the end of those five and a
half hours so design wise I think these
are kind of great and that's something
Bose has always been king at these are
lightweight like those the cups have a
good amount of padding the top band is
padded
there are plenty flexible enough to not
be squeezing your head all the time and
getting uncomfortable and then they beat
the bows by being USB type-c it's
actually funny a lot of people see these
and immediately think this this copper
accent at the top and it looks like the
USBC port but it's not that's actually
the microphone at the top of both ear
cups the USBC port is down here at the
bottom but yeah you can use the same
charger as you already have for your
phone or your laptop or whatever other
USB see things you have and the battery
life lives up to the 20 plus hours
longer than the surface headphones it's
great okay I'm really raving about these
I'm making them sound pretty perfect
trust me though they're not perfect
nothing's perfect I think in an ideal
world I would combine these with the
surface headphones and their their dials
and their design I think those those
function a little bit better but here
are some things about these that aren't
quite perfect first of all my number one
complaint is the controls there are only
two physical buttons on these all the
rest of the controls all the rest of the
work is all done by swiping and tapping
on the right ear cup which is a small
touchpad so double tap to play and pause
swiping up and down to change the volume
and forward and backward to change
tracks it can be a bit fidgety it
doesn't work every time but you kind of
get used to it another thing is when you
take the headphones off they just keep
playing like normal headphones but the
surface headphones would detect when you
took them off your head and they'd pause
and when you put them back on they would
keep playing again these don't and I
kind of miss that and then the two
buttons that are physical on these are
the power button and the noise
cancellation / ambient mode switch which
by default doubles as the Google
assistant button so you can hold it to
speak and talk to Google assistant which
is cool without ever you know taking
your phone out your pocket you can ask
Google assistant a question out loud and
it'll answer that question it can also
read your notifications when you ask it
to but even with all of that I still
prefer the surface headphones physical
dials still for volume and then there is
also what is known as the cold weather
issue with these headphones there been a
couple reports about it or articles
about it but basically when you take
these out in you know freezing
conditions or sub-zero weather
apparently the touch pads will start to
register phantom touches so without you
ever touching them it'll start to play
and pause your muse
and change the volume and the tracks and
randomly stop playing that's pretty
rough now I have been using these
outside you know as low as 40 degrees
Fahrenheit so not below freezing but I
haven't had this issue yet to with as
cold as it is in some parts of the world
right now it's worth noting that these
do seem to have that issue and I don't
know if it can be fixed with a software
update it may be possible but as of
right now if there's a cold weather
issue that makes these unusable in
certain climates that's kind of a bummer
so I have to let you guys know about it
also these headphones come with a good
hard case like most other over your
headphones but I find that the way they
fold is really annoying maybe it's just
that I haven't gotten used to it yet but
that's a small nitpick honestly the case
itself is fine and if wind or anything
blows hard enough down on you from above
the mics on the top will pick that up
and you'll hear it as a sort of a fuzzy
static I only notice this because when
I'm on the airplane which is where a lot
of people will listen to these I had the
vents above me and they were blowing
down like directly into those
microphones so you just kind of adjust
that anger fine oh and the left ear cup
has an NFC logo on it that can be used
to tap to pair on the side of the
headphones with an NFC naval device so
that's pretty cool I'm gonna start using
that more often to connect or to
disconnect but these headphones only
pair to one device at a time and that
might not sound like a big deal but when
you get used to headphones with multiple
device connectivity and seamless
switching that is a big time convenience
with these surface headphones or any
other pair of headphones that supports
multiple devices you can be playing
something like literally music from your
phone on the headphones pull out your
iPad which is already paired to the
headphones and hit play on some video or
Netflix or whatever you're doing and
it'll instantly take over on the
headphones and there's seamless
switching back and forth between devices
without dealing with the frustration of
Bluetooth with these you still have to
deal with the pain of Bluetooth
sometimes being kind of fidgety and not
connecting on the first try and having
to do it again and the whole pairing
process is kind of annoying so yeah just
I hope the next version of these that
they make the m4s
have that multiple device connectivity
but these don't I wish they did I really
missed that but other than that I
I love these headphones they're matte
black mostly all the way around which
you know I love but you also got this
little copper accent at the top with the
sony logo and the microphones and it's
also on the zipper of the hard case so
how they look is great how they sound is
great how they feel is great they're
ideal for flying of course and they're
also the go to pick for just travel
headphones in general and and they're
just great for cancelling out the noise
of an office or a coffee shop or really
anywhere that noise canceling headphones
are good so yeah that's that's pretty
much all there is to say about
headphones
I'm just glad these ended up on my radar
so shout out to those of you who are
leaving comments on the videos shoutout
to vipre for yelling at me on his
livestream to go buy these shout out to
everyone in the comment section of my
last headphones video that got me to
actually pick these up and i'm glad i'm
using them now these are now permanent
backpack material so i'll drop a link
below if you guys want to check these
out for yourself I'll leave a link to
the other headphone video but that's
basically it thanks for watching I'm
gonna go back to working on that secret
project now catch you guys in the next
one peace